Hello, everybody. Uh,
my name is Abhishek Sharma. Everybody
calls me Abhi.
I work for LPL Financial,
where I lead the
technology platform from trading and investment
management.
The time is 2:30 p.m.
Um,
also known as the post lunch
danger zone,
the lunch is settling in,
attention span,
well, it's
somewhat conflicting.
So before we get started,
let's get some, uh,
energy in the room with some
show of hand exercises.
Who here is attending the
reinvent conference for the first time?
Wow. All right.
Uh, hopefully, the experience has been good
so far. It's one of the best industry conferences.
Who has been ascertained at least
5 or more times.
Got some veterans in the room.
Uh,
who has already done 10,000 steps today.
All right,
20,000, here we come.
Uh,
and this is the most important question.
Who has enough swag that is
not gonna fit in the carry-on luggage?
And he's debating now, do I check in my
bag? Do I buy another bag, right?
Happens a lot more than you think,
um.
On a serious note,
let's, a couple of questions related
to the topic at hand, which is trading
platform.
How many here have done
any sort of stock trading in their life?
Most of you guys, as expected, right?
How many here understand
what happens after a trade is
done, after you buy and sell a security.
Great, some experts in the room as well, great.
All right, so let's get to it.
Before we begin the session, I wanna start the session
by thanking AWS.
The partnership has been truly critical
in our journey.
As we modernize and build
the next generation trading platform,
AWS provides us the tools that we
need
scale, resiliency,
access to the emerging AI platforms,
so we appreciate the collaboration and we
look forward to make LPL
the platform of choice for advisers.
So,
future of trading platform. Why build
a next generation trading platform?
We are at the inflection point.
In wealth management.
Speed, scale, resiliency,
intelligence,
those are
not nice to have anymore.
They are mandatory table stakes
to have any competitive advantage in the
market. The next
few minutes, we'll walk you through
how we're designing the next gen trading platform
at LPL,
a platform.
That is designed not just to keep up
with the market,
but to anticipate and adapt
to it. This is
a story
of moving away from legacy dependencies,
traditional architecture
to fully intelligent cloud native
trading platform for the next decade.
Let's get to it.
So we got a jam-packed agenda today.
There's no technology problem
solution without a business problem, so we'll kick
off, we'll talk a little bit more about
overview of what is wealth management
industry, what are the,
what's happening in wealth management world.
Who is LPL? What is LPL's business model?
Zoom in to the trading platforms at LPL.
What are we up to today?
We'll set some context from what are
the business goals,
technology goals that we're trying to solve for aspirationally.
We'll go through our journey in the cloud.
Transformation is always a journey. It's never a big bang.
We'll see how we are approaching that.
We'll talk about our current state
platform, our aspirational next generation
architecture.
And we'll
go at the end with some deep dive use cases
where we're applying some of the cloud principles
and it is 2025. There is no presentation
worth attending without the mention of AI,
so we'll talk about AI at the end,
um,
things that we are up to and things we have aspirationally
that we have in pipeline as we go,
right. And we'll save some
time at Q&A if we can't get to the
Q&A because I know everybody wanna rush to the next session,
so find us offline. My team, his
entire team is sitting here, so depending on the questions,
we'll help do our best to answer your questions.
Right,
wealth management. So when we did show of hands,
all of you have done, most of you have
done some type of trading.
So what is wealth management industry?
At its core,
wealth management is simply helping
people make smart
decisions with their money,
how to save it,
how to invest it, how to grow it,
and most importantly,
how to protect it.
Is, is the guidance given to
anybody at every financial moment
of their life.
As an industry, wealth management
is huge.
144 trillion assets
under management
across 300,000 financial advisors,
68 million clients.
That's a big opportunity. That's a big market.
And The
last two years, especially now,
has been, is an amazing time
to be in wealth management.
What we call it is a generational wealth
transfer is underway. What that means
is there's 100 trillion assets under management,
which baby boomers are transitioning these assets
to the next generations.
This next generation is.
More tech savvy
Digital native,
this next generation is pushing the curve.
They are demanding
personalization,
instant art responses, intelligent
insights, right?
Something they are very much used to
from the consumer tech partners.
Opportunity is huge.
Challenge,
how do you meet to that expectation
for systems that has existed for decades?
Great technology challenge opportunity to have.
Let's bring
close to LPL.
LPL Financial is the
one broker dealer in the country.
We are a Fortune 500 company.
What is
an independent broker dealer?
Simply, Independent Broker dealer is a
firm that enables financial advisors
to run their own business
while providing the backbone they need.
Technology,
operations, compliance, what have you.
And LPL
has 32,000 financial advisors.
We do 2.3 trillion assets under
management. What
differentiates LPL
from the rest of the competition is.
The flexibility
and the scale.
The ability for the financial advisors
to choose technology and tools that
define design their own practice is
amazing. This freedom of
flexibility, this freedom of choice.
is core to our value proposition.
But from a technology perspective, that it creates
a great opportunity,
because now your platform has to adapt
to small business, to
large scale institutions.
We are a very customer centric
organization. Our mission.
Is to help
our clients success at every step of
the way.
Our vision
is to be the best wealth management firm.
To be the best, the technology has to be
the best.
It has to be adaptive,
cutting edge, future ready.
Let's click down
within LPL. Let's talk about creating investment
management.
I define trading in our world as
a connective tissue for financial advisers
to the market.
When the trade is done,
behind the scene, there are
hundreds of high performance
systems.
They all work in unison.
To execute,
settle a trade
with the speed, accuracy
and transparency.
If you look at this picture,
The workflow is pretty standard.
Somebody generates order, order is
placed, it goes through process, ultimately
it gets executed.
While this is happening in our world, we
have 2,000+ checks running in sub milliseconds.
And any trading system
has its own complexity
that's in their own ecosystem like in LPL we
have 78 systems, 70 to 80
systems that run together,
but a trading system also relies
on multiple partners out there, market
centers, fintech organizations, right, which
makes the complexity
to the next level.
It's a complex
ecosystem,
but from a user's standpoint, it should be
simple
and very seamless.
All right. There
is no technology with business objective.
Tech for technology's sake doesn't really last,
right? So before we define our
technology aspiration technology
goals.
Let's bring in something that we all
are comfortable with.
So when we trade as a user,
when you go and do a trade,
what are the basic
expectations when you trade?
First of all, my trades should be very,
very secure,
no brainer.
I should be able to trade whenever
I want to.
Always on systems.
When I trade, I should get the responses.
Instant, near real time.
And
it should be cheaper to do so,
right? So when you look
at enterprise grade platforms
like LPL,
these objectives don't change.
They just scale up
1000 times over.
We have to deliver on the same fundamentals
as you would expect when you do a trade, but
at institutional level.
Now to define our business goals, business
objectives,
what are the basic business outcomes we typically expect?
Customer satisfaction,
in our case, adviser satisfaction,
high customer retention,
advisor retention.
Reduce, cheaper, reduced cost
to serve,
ultimately that will lead to better margin
expansion.
So what technology goals do we need to do to get to
that?
Same thing, the first one.
Zero security incidents.
Needless to say, wealth management is a highly regulated
industry. We want to have 100% compliance
in our industry.
We want systems that are ultra
resilient,
always on,
and very fast recovery mode when
the failure happens.
And training systems are designed for peak. You
don't design trading system for average volume.
You always designed for the peak, right?
So 10x scale, sub-millisecond
performance,
and obviously make it cheaper as you do so.
Now LPL, if you look at LPL, we are a very
fast growing organization,
both organically and inorganically.
As we add more advisers on the platform,
those advisors will add more clients,
more accounts on the platform.
More trading volume.
Regardless of how much trading volume happens,
every adviser, every client account expects
speed, scale,
institutional grade resiliency.
And how are we doing that?
So we have two objectives to do, to meet
those expectations.
First, we want to leverage
AWS Cloud to provide
the speed, scale, and resiliency commitment
to our customers.
And we wanna infuse intelligence
in our platform, leveraging AI
platforms like SageMaker, Bedrock, and others.
The next slides will look at exactly how we
are trying to do that.
So our cloud journey,
the journey is a very appropriate term, especially
large scale organizations like us, right? It's
never a big bang to go to the cloud.
So we have been on a cloud journey for a few years
now, but to keep it simple, we'll anchor
ourselves in 2024.
To understand how we are doing our cloud
journey,
this is more of an iterative fashion where
every year, every step feeds into the next
step. It's a,
it's not a migration,
it's a reinvention.
I had to use the word reinvention somewhere,
uh, uh, but
it's truly a reinvention every step of the way,
um.
So the way we, we, the way we
deliberately began a cloud journey, the analogy
I can give, the best analogy we can come up with is
building a skyscraper.
You wanna get to a very fault tolerant system,
highly resilient platform.
It's like building like a skyscraper. You don't start
a skyscraper with the 40th floor. You
build a foundation, reinforce the core,
then you add electricity, plumbing, automations,
what have you.
Every level
helps the next level to withstand more load
and grow taller and operate smarter.
Our journey is very similar.
Up until 2024.
We started migrating
more and more of our processes from
our on-prem data centers to the cloud.
We have multiple critical systems running
in EKS and we'll see more in some use
cases. We
are adopting more AI. We have machine
learning algorithms which are
used on Sagemaker.
This year has been a lot about auto scaling.
Now one thing about auto scaling is, uh,
EKS, as we all know, scales automatically
if it's, it's set up in the right way.
You gotta have a good independent
system,
so we started
decoupling our platforms this year so
that we can harness auto scaling. In some
instances we have seen 10x scale
just by tweaking how we design our
system, and we'll we have a good use case to talk
about that today.
As we go into next year, we are on a journey of
enhancing our resiliency of the platform.
Like today, we are
multi-availability zone,
and we want to transform that to a multi-region,
multi-availability zone.
We'll do so by reducing our
on-prem dependencies, on-prem
data dependencies.
We do so by
incrementally first trying to go to an active
passive journey
if you, if you have done any multi-region implementations,
you realize that
going from active passive to active active,
especially for right systems is a different ball game.
So we start with active active passive trend
towards active active.
Our target state is to be a really a
system that is.
Very fault tolerant,
recovers in sub millisecond.
Is using AI as a digital
practice within the infrastructure itself.
So this is an iterative and incremental journey
we're on.
So let's look at our current state architecture.
I, like I said,
We have our on-prem data center,
right? And
we have multi availability zone in the
cloud.
Our workflows today for many instances
designed to handshake between on-prem to the cloud.
So we have a dedicated handshake, dedicated
line pipe between our on-prem
to the cloud,
which helps reduce the latency for any of the
workflows that become chatty. We try to avoid chattiness,
but if, if there's chattiness, it reduces the latency.
Some of the key components that we have in the,
in our, in our design from Amazon,
AWS perspective.
We use
Um, We use S3
bucket for our presentation layer and
content rendering
very standard.
We use EKS Kuberti's surveless
design and architecture
for um intensive processes in
many spaces. It's actually designed to
auto scale and self-heal. They're
returning to a self field. We'll talk a little bit more about that
later. When
it comes to data,
it's uh
different options depending on the need
for our relational need, which is a pretty common
requirement for high transaction
throughput systems,
we have Postres SQL,
uh, we use the Dynamo DB
for our
document docu document databases for more
mostly read read, uh, use cases.
We use memory DB for low latency,
high computing in memory processes.
Um, Kafka is a big part of our ecosystem.
Uh, it serves as a big message broker.
It reduces the cascading
dependencies. It reduces any, any
failures that may happen from one system to another.
Um,
around that, we use SageMaker heavily
today for our machine learning algorithms and some
of the AI use cases.
Um, CloudWatch is a big part of our
instrumentation
along with, uh,
any observability, end to end observability.
Right, so this is our current state.
Designed uh it's
multi availability zone,
works in tandem with on-prem.
And it works for what it is now, but
we are on a journey to we are transforming this into
something more futuristic and ready for the
next generation.
So next-gen architecture
is trending.
First, the biggest thing that you see here is that there is
no on-prem dependency, right?
Especially for what we
call as tier one
critical applications.
Uh
When you remove the on-prem dependency
at that time,
it's easier to harness the
full. Power of the cloud,
your resiliency becomes truly from end
to end. Your failovers become simpler,
so we are in the journey of transforming
a cloud, our on-prem dependencies
to the cloud, and which is an interesting
thing if you have any done any of this cloud transformation
from on-prem.
On-print systems, traditionally, the way
it is, is not really designed for
small components. You gotta break down the dependencies,
sequence the work, we do it in a very risk-averse,
high tested manner.
We are trending towards a
An active, active multi-region environment,
especially which is gonna be real,
especially without with reducing the on-prem
dependency
and like I said,
we'll start with active passive and we are going to trend
towards active active.
One of the biggest challenges that we are seeing
and we we are working on it is
how do you make sure the data is consistent
for right instances on multi-region.
So we're looking at Aurora DB as a big use
case for us, uh, natively supports this.
Um, how do you orchestrate
requests between multiple regions
in an active, active way?
So those are the problems that we are solving, um.
In the next gen architecture we will also be
also adopting
uh Bedrock along with SageMaker. We
feel Bedrock because as we adopt more Gen
AI and LLM, I think Bedrock
gives us better integration into our
core workflows and becomes an and
there's a learning curve is slightly easier.
So this is our next generation architecture
that we are solving for,
right? Um
Most of it, many of it actually is underway,
and we want to start getting some stuff in production
early next year.
Now, um
we break water.
Let's click down a little bit in terms of
some of the use cases that we
are supporting today, uh,
the architecture that we looked at,
let's see some use cases in action in terms of how
that cloud and this native AWS helped us
get there. So Klein
works rebalancer,
Klein works rebalancer is our
uh. Flagship
homegrown trading platform.
This platform is designed on the principle
of what we call as models-based trading.
Now what is model space trading?
Now. Typically
an advisor will have hundreds of clients,
let's say
each client, as you would imagine,
would have different investment needs,
different goals, investment objectives,
risk profiles.
Some clients
may want
an aggressive portfolio,
high reward,
high risk. Some may want conservative portfolio,
low reward, low risk.
For example, if someone is close to retirement, you
may see a more conservative portfolio like that.
Now, advisors would typically
create portfolios to meet the client's need
as per their investment objectives, their goals,
and that's good.
But markets is always changing, right? Our market
is always moving, always changing. I mean
if you think about this year,
think of the big market movers this year
interest rate changes, tariff
changes, tariff changes,
AI disruptions,
those are pretty common instances in the market
and when those swings happen.
The portfolio completely deviates
from what it was intended to do.
A portfolio that was supposed to be conservative
will become moderately aggressive.
And that's not good. Uh,
an adviser will have to financial advisor
in this case will have to take prompt action toward
any market exposure for the client.
Now, without automation, this
would be a very tedious manual
process, account by account, client by client.
Not scalable,
error prone.
How do we solve this?
Models based practice
in models based practice, advisor sets up models
and each model will be flagged by metadata
like this model is for aggressive portfolio,
conservative portfolio,
an adviser will assign the model to the
account so ultimately this would be a
one to many relationship from model to accounts.
So when the trading happens, advisor is not trading the
account, the adviser is actually trading on the
models.
This principle is exactly the principle client
grocery Balance is built on.
Client was rebalancing today does
millions of drift checks
in parallel.
It does executions, trade executions
automatically,
does so by being fully compliant with
the seamless
experience for the advisors.
The best analogy I see of client rebalancer
is, uh,
is like a GPS when you put a target destination,
your GPS will recalibrate, reroute
based on the traffic pattern.
That's exactly what client rebalancer does.
Thousands of accounts,
millions of trades calibrate in the
client rebalancer as the market moves,
it will suggest automatically and bring the
accounts back into their original goal.
Today, on Clein Works Rebalancer, we have
14,000 advisors.
And this has been a deliberate incremental journey
for the last 5 years. If you recall,
we have 32 32,000
advisors at LPL Financial.
And we are slowly rolling this
platform out to more and more advisers incrementally.
We have done more than 70 million trades
on this platform, and we do a million
drift checks every day on this platform.
So this is the
product side of the equation setting the business
context.
Now let's take a simple use case.
One use case with inclined grocery balancer
powered by AWS for hyperscaling.
When a trade happens.
Each trade,
like, let's say climber's rebalance a trade happens,
each trade will do
50+ checks.
Think about things like what are the common things
if I wanna trade
is my account OK? Account details,
uh, what is the price right now in the market? What
is the, what is the licensing check? Uh, what is
the compliance rules for this, for this trade?
Imagine 50+ calls,
thousands of trades across hundreds of accounts, across
hundreds of advisers. We're looking at hundreds
of thousands of trade volume going through
every minute.
The way we design the platform, so if you've, if
you keep up with me from the left to right,
imagine a large rebalance rate comes in
from the, from the, from the advisor.
We, we run an orchestrator.
This orchestrator looks at the function and sees
how do we smartly design this hundreds
of thousands of crates into chunks.
So design, it breaks into small mini
batches.
All these chunks, these mini batches,
go to Kafka, which is our broker.
The me and Kafka is amazing
because it, it has guaranteed delivery.
So it goes to Kafka on
the other side is where the brain is,
the rebalancer. The rebalance algorithm
is sitting on EKS cluster,
right? It's designed
to auto scale.
That the algorithm of rebalance
is made in a way is completely independent
of each other. It's harnessing
the full power of EKS for auto scaling, so
in real time, it will look at
what's my CPU
right now, what is the memory utilization,
what is the queue depth on my Kafka
stream right now.
And based on that, it will
scale up or spawn more instances of
rebalancer with the EKS.
Now, if you remember I said something about 2000
checks that happened.
More than 200 checks from that actually
are pre-trade validation.
So pre-trade validation
to even know if this trade can be done or not,
right? And you want to do the
trade checks as soon as possible. So
what we do here in Rebalancer is
We do in-process caching.
Of all the data and the rules
for 200+ trade checks,
so instantaneously we get some millisecond
feedback and the trade cannot be done,
it's not in good order, failed from here,
it's kicked back
to to the queue and will not make its way forward.
Right,
so we had rebalancer,
IKEAS, auto scaling in process caching
for some uh pre-trade validation
from here.
There are intensive processes that happen
for every trade, every rebalance.
So what we did, we applied the principle of parallellyzation
over here. So we looked at all the 60 plus
code uh microservices database
calls happen. We grouped them
as per the dependency map and see what
can be run in parallel. So we decided we
run everything in parallel and just rebalancing
calling them and they're designed to not block each other.
Now from here
Every system,
right, has reads and rights. Now Res has different
problems, rights are different problems, right?
So from here,
we apply the paradigm of CQRS
command query responsibility segregation.
Most of you know about that.
So for the rights we optimize the
rights writings of one server, but
the rights are not transactional. The rights
are batched, buffered together so that we
have less hits to the database.
From here the reads span
out and the reads are going to the read
instances
because there are more reads than rights in the system, so
the reads optimized for that
and we also do a lot of caching
in memory DB
uh in AWS.
Which helps for any, any computations,
anything that may be intensive, we precalculate,
get it ready in memory for further steps.
Now one thing that we are doing now is
adaptive scaling on the read instances,
uh, because this system is heavy read,
so we want the system to, like I said, the EKS
automatically scales, we want the reads to automatically
scale, so we're doing adaptive scaling on the reeds.
Throughout this life cycle, we use cloud
watch to end to end observability.
When the trade happens
from that it gets a correlation ID
because obviously we got a heavy logging,
full traceability of every trade
and that trade will tell us that token
tells us how did the trade navigate, which cluster
it went through, did it go through, how long did it take,
so we have I use cloudWatch for that.
We also do, uh, now all the systems
are designed to self- alert, self
feel the AES cluster, especially,
but we also do synthetics.
So what it, what synthetics, what we do basically
we create a transaction which mimics
how an advisor would do this.
So we run that transaction
for end to end on the system
just every, every iteratively
so that we know if there's
a problem with the platform we would know before the users
knows it. Today the
system is running 1,000s
of transactions per second. We have seen
almost a million transactions in peak volume.
And
it's, it's ready for more,
uh. All
right, AI
as promised. So we'll talk about some of our use
cases we're doing in AI,
uh.
So
our philosophy in LPL we truly
believe the power of AI that AI is
here
to help advisers get
smarter and more efficient.
But we believe in a human in the loop approach
as AI is suggesting.
Outcomes
As AI is suggesting um.
Smart recommendations inside, advisor
will still be in control,
taking those insights.
So let's look at the first use case.
So market center outage, right? So
once when a trade happens,
right, the trade
doesn't just just go and execute. There are
a set of intermediaries that have that
that. Before it
reaches the market center, some of the intermediaries
are within the company, some are external to the market,
but the critical end point is the market center is
where actually the trades happen.
Now these market centers
sometimes have slowness, and there are multiple market centers,
right, not just one, there are many market centers.
But sometimes there are challenges, problems,
and outages even in market centers.
And by the time we get alerts, it's kind
of late for us to know.
To react to it, what happens is that
there's an outage in a market center,
orders keep piling on.
The system.
Worse, new orders keep on piling
on as well.
If you look at from um adviser's
perspective, from a user's perspective, the user would
say, oh, my order did not go
through. Let me try it again.
Duplicates happen.
Complete operational nightmare
when you start getting duplicates in the system.
So our goal was to lift shift and
know as much as we can from market center
outage ahead of that.
So how did, how did we do that?
So we created a workflow.
Now this workflow
first feeds all the real-time trades
and executions
to an algorithm.
This algorithm.
Detects patterns for any anomalies
and if the anomaly is detected, it will
transition the anomalies and outcome
to the operational
team, and they will start taking actions from there.
What algorithm do we use? We use an algorithm
called random cut forest, which
is a time series anomaly
detection algorithm.
That's first use case, and we'll talk about architecture
after this, like how we did that using SageMaker.
The second use case we have is our ETF
classification.
Now, obviously in trading
there are a lot of securities.
You got equities, you got mutual funds,
you got ETF which is a type of equities.
Now if you know ETFs, ETFs have
different holdings that go in there,
right? Based on what goes in an ETF,
we have to classify ETF
in different categories.
For example, let's say there's an ETTF for
crypto, ETF for commodities,
ETF for foreign funds.
Based on the metadata of the ETF,
what it holds,
we have to classify because
there is a regulatory implication
because certain ETFs, there has to be licensing
checks, there has to be
compliance rules, there have to be trainings that
the user advisor has to go through.
So this, this is a pretty critical workflow
where we gotta flag and categorize the ETF
appropriately.
Now, typically, traditionally, this was done more manually,
where somebody would go.
Look at the data,
look at the prospectus, as we call it,
look at the metadata for the ETF
and manually classify it.
So we
decided how do we start because and and ETF
is is a fast changing market. There are new ETFs
always added in the marketplace.
So how do we automate that?
So we again, we created a workflow here which
runs nightly. It takes an ETFs
as we go. It runs through a model, a
trained model,
and that model would suggest
what ETF this category should be
categorized as
and operational staff reviews and accepts
it. The algorithm we used was ANN,
artificial neural network, which is an unsupervised
model for doing so.
With high accuracy
Now, let's get to the
architecture of how we did this.
Um,
so,
any AI model has to be trained,
right? You gotta have the data,
historical data,
wherever you get the data, so it gets better
outcome, better results.
We store the data in the RDS, Aurora
postgrad database.
For example, the first use case, the market center outage,
the data for that is all the historical trades
and executions data.
The data stored over there.
The second use case, which is the classification,
all the security master, all the metadata around
it is stored in the database.
From here, we have a lambda function. This
lambda function
picks this data, historical data, which is
curated, updated every day.
Massages it, gets it ready, dumps
the data for
learning in 3 bucket.
And this is where the heart comes into play, which is the sage
maker. So our sage maker is
where we train
and uh other models reside.
So Sage maker in this case will pick up the trained
data, the, the training data,
run through it, train it, and once it's
trained, it's ready to be published
and it's available as an endpoint,
as a model, trained model for for downstream
consumption. Very simple
workflow Now
let's run these couple of use cases.
The first use case, uh,
in the real-time anomaly detection, right? So
as the traits.
Hundreds and thousands of trades are going in real time.
The stream of data
is picked up by this lambda on the right function,
right side. It picks up this data,
runs this data via the train model, that
endpoint.
Like in this case, the
random cut cut forest algorithm, it
will detect the time series data,
tell us that, hey, there's an anomaly. If there's
an anomaly, immediately it alerts
the staff
then the data is fed back to the RDS for
future learning based on the decisions that
uh the model took.
Same thing for the ATF classification.
New ETF comes,
go to the lambda function,
runs it by the train model end point,
gets outcome,
gives outcome to the operator,
and, uh.
And it's ready in the RDS instance.
So yeah, so this works and uh it's
fully functional, it's really helped us a lot, these couple,
at least these couple of use cases.
Um,
to some of the use cases that we have underway
right now.
Um,
so the first one is a trading back office
automation.
Right, so this is our multi-agenttic
solution, um,
that we are currently, it's underway on our side.
So let's give me some, let me give some business context
to this problem that we're trying to solve here.
Um.
So, so when we all invest money,
what is our goal?
Grow money, right? We want to make more money.
When the portfolio grows, what happens?
More capital gains taxes. The more
more taxes
has high impact on accounts which are larger
sizes.
Especially for ultra high net worth
uh clients,
the tax consequences can be huge,
and they, uh, there are typically tax
thresholds that, hey, this for this account,
this is the max tax I would like
to pay every year,
so they're tax thresholds.
Now we saw that rebalancer itself
is a complicated process. Now imagine
a rebalancer overlaid
with tax awareness,
tax optimization, tax consequences
gets different level of complex.
We have an algorithm that takes 50
plus variables.
Into account
now when we run and each 5th
of these variables
has an interdependency
if one changes this impact to the other one
and they're highly highly sensitive
so tweaking those variables
in the algorithm
and getting the right return and the
right tax outcomes, it's
a very difficult process
and very hard to scale.
So we decided we explore different possibilities.
So one of the things that we're looking at
is using a multi-agentic uh agentic
AI framework to solve this problem.
So what is an agent, as we all know, agent is nothing
but a model model that has a role and
takes actions based on the role.
So the first model, our first model and first agent
we have is a rebalancer.
So this rebalancer model, this agent is trained
with. 22
data sets. First data set is
the algorithm that I talked about, it is trained with
the algorithm,
it's trained with this 50+ parameters,
these variables,
different combinations, what does each variable
do? The other set of
data that it is trained with is
the historical runs, right? So
if there was a run for a tax trade rebalancer,
especially which is done manually today.
Good outcomes, not so favorable outcomes,
regardless, whatever data is, it's actually trained with that
data. So imagine now
we are doing hundreds of these requests in a day. A
request comes in,
the rebalancer agent runs the
request, gets some outcome, right?
This outcome goes back.
Based on the favorable outcome, it'll go to the validation
agent. Now validation agent, its role
is very simple.
Rebalance it just looks at the rebalance as one thing
validation looks around the ecosystem of
an account, account a client.
Is this outcome gonna create any cascading
dependencies and impact?
Based on that, the validation agent on a happy
path will approve it and it goes
to the trading agent, which, which I'm
dumbing down as an agent, which is more complex,
but trading agent will just
execute the trades with the market makers,
market centers.
Now, the other part where the validation
agent
fails based on whatever the rule may be,
it'll send the response back with the appropriate feedback
to the rebalancer agent.
So that it can reprocess this request.
So it's an agentic loop, but in
some of our
initial studies, it has given us 10x
scale already
in terms of what it can do from the throughput standpoint.
So we're very excited about this uh as an agent,
uh, multi agent AI solution.
Uh, next use case is the model suggestions for
account portfolio that's being uh, that's being worked
on right now.
So. So we talked about models-based
trading. So the industry is
gone, trended towards
models-based trading.
But advisors, in many
cases,
some part of the book is not catered
towards model-based trading.
Why? Historical reasons is very common,
right? But the, the process
to actually convert the platform
or the accounts to a models based practice
or around the models is a very
operationally intensive process and not really scalable
so we are, we are working on an AI solution and
it will do it will be very simple. It will look
at advisor.
The current book.
And the current book and the holdings for
the accounts,
accounts which have models, accounts that did not have models,
based on the book, based on the accounts and the holdings,
it will suggest the models that the
adviser can use
to transition towards models based practice.
It's the ultimate, uh, it's a very efficiency
play for the advisers over here
because we don't want advisers to spend time in operational
work versus spend more time with the customers.
Right, so this is our end of the presentation.
Um, uh, this journey has
been pretty fun. It's truly been a team effort
for multiple teams, organizations within
the company,
uh, technology, business, product, and,
uh,
thank, uh, and our partners, and I'll call out,
uh, cognizant for the partnership
and support during the process.
Great, um,
so I appreciate everybody coming in and we are here if
you have any questions. Find us on LinkedIn for the
team, and, uh, I'm
happy to connect with you guys. Thank you so much for attending the
session. Thank you.